do you look through hate comments of
yourself what we're trying to do is have
some fun and make sure social media
doesn't destroy our lives
making sure you're happy first is the
biggest thing the trailer for the dimlio
show just dropped and it's chock full of
drama and tears it's crazy to think that
this is real life in the first look at
dixie and charlie demilio's new reality
show fans catch a sneak peek at the tick
tock star's rise to fame can you ever
really imagine a hundred million people
you can get famous really fast on tick
tock i don't know how charlie blew up
it's crazy and the moments leading up to
the launch of dixie's music career
starting music with a huge audience is
very scary
this is the discovery process we're
figuring out what you're good at
i just feel held to a very high standard
the 19 year old who currently has over
54 million followers on tick tock
dropped her first single be happy back
in 2020
sometimes i don't want to be happy
don't hold it against me if i'm down
just leave me there let me be sad
and in the trailer we see dixie's
boyfriend noah beck consoling her after
she received some hate online
there's always going to be people that
hate on you for no reason
making sure you're happy first is the
biggest thing cute right and get this
when e.t caught up with the soccer
player turned tick-tock star back in
january he said he could see himself
marrying dixie i could definitely see
myself marrying dixie and like that's
the
that's the goal right i don't want to
waste my time like i don't want to deal
with someone if i'm not
if the intention is not to date it's not
miriam yeah but yeah i i i think she's
my forever person and if all that wasn't
cute enough he also said he had a crush
on dixie before she even knew he existed
the 20 year old was still going to
college at the university of portland as
a soccer recruit before the coronavirus
pandemic put those dreams on hold and he
found stardom on tick tock it was crazy
because i obviously she was very
beautiful and
but i i just never thought i would have
a chance like i was like i'm here in
portland like in a dorm room she's in la
like
doing crazy stuff and while fans can
look forward to seeing the couple and
all their cuteness on the show charlie's
also dishing on her love life to go
through a public breakup was terrible it
was right person wrong time you love him
but back in april 2020 the teen who has
over
122 million followers on tick tock went
through a very public split with her
boyfriend chase hudson aka lil hoody
fans can also expect to see a lot of
charlie and dixie's parents mark and
heidi who moved the family from
connecticut to l.a to support their
daughter's dreams we had a very happy
life in connecticut and this is a risk
sometimes i feel like it's my fault my
family's out here it's definitely a lot
of pressure on me in the trailer mama
and papa demilio open up about trying to
make sure their girls have a somewhat
normal life they're normal kids that
doesn't change with a following this is
a look at your 2021. is there room for
dance and to be a kid i want to try and
keep that as normal as it was we're
trying to get you miss you i've never
snuck out that is something that i've
always wanted to do we won't look we'll
leave all the doors open of course all
this comes after the fam teased to e.t
that a reality show was in the works
back in 2020 is a reality show something
that you guys would do
um
i mean
yeah definitely something that would be
super fun for people to kind of
see what goes on when
we're not just posting pictures and mark
and heidi opened up about watching dixie
and charlie's stars rise it's been fun
it's a lot more positive than negative
which has been nice
and just seeing um
the whole thing happen so quickly i
think that was that's probably the
craziest part of it we kind of just are
rolling with it and
just keeping uh the number one
thing close to us is our family and our
and being there for each
[Music]
other you